very sad news about these two NHS nurses
Katy and also our death toll that's gone
through three thousands a day yeah again
we are seeing these significant
increases in the number of deaths day on
day but we should say that we are in the
place where many of the government
scientific advisors thought we would be
at this stage according to the models
that they have predicted significant
increases though before we get into the
UK numbers we should just say if you are
doing the maths at home if you add up
England Wales Northern Ireland in
Scotland you might notice that actually
there's a discrepancy in the number of
total deaths in the UK that's because
the UK total that we are given is
separate from the Department of Health
now their figure we believe according to
the number crunchers that we've got
working on this actually takes the
figure for Northern Ireland in Scotland
from the day before so actually that's
why you'll see that discrepancy but it
does give us a really good insight into
exactly what's happening number wise so
let's just look at the UK figures now to
start with shall we so in the UK we know
that the total number of deaths now
stands at three thousand six hundred and
five that is an increase on the previous
day of 680 for a 23 percent increase and
now the one that many of the scientific
advisers are paying claying
paying close attention to though is the
number of confirmed cases that now is up
to thirty eight thousand one hundred
sixty-eight an increase of four thousand
four hundred and fifty what the
scientific advisers want to see there is
if that is starting to flatten out so
he'll be interesting to see what is said
at the number-10 press briefing later on
whether or not they were happy with that
figure now if we take the individual
figures for the different countries
having a look at England now we know
that the total number of deaths in
England has now increased to three
thousand three hundred and two an
increase of six hundred and four higher
than yesterday but in the range of which
the scientific advisors had predicted
taking the figures for Scotland we know
that there has been an increase of 46
deaths in Scotland taking the total
there to 172 if we compare that to
what's happening in Wales we know now
that the Wales total as
at 172 that is an increase of 24 and
taking finally the figures for Northern
Ireland the total deaths in Northern
Ireland now stands at 48 an increase of
12 which is actually double of the
number that we had on the day before I
think what's interesting actually as
well
is if you break down the figures for
England actually the growth rate in
London appears to be slowing the number
of deaths in London is at 161 we found
out this lunchtime but the rest of the
UK appears to be catching up so we know
that the numbers are accelerating in the
Midlands they now stand at 150 coming
out of the Midlands and in the Northwest
it's also accelerating eighty eight
deaths came from the Northwest sadly as
well we we have to confirm this
afternoon we've heard the case the
confirmation of another death of an NHS
nurse Amy O'Rourke was 38 years old she
died from Cove at 19 she worked at the
Queen Elizabeth the Queen Mother
Hospital in Margate and Kent
it was the same hospital where she had
been being treated for the coronavirus
social media posts paying tribute to her
we know there's one from her daughter
where she describes her mother as being
an angel saying the family is trying
their very best at the moment to stay
strong and on a GoFundMe page that's
been set up in her name it talks about
how Amy gave her life to make sure that
other people survived the virus and
sadly it isn't the only case of a nurse
that we've had today who has died from
the corona virus we also had
confirmation from the husband of Ahriman
Nasreen who worked for Walsall manor
hospital she was 36 year old 36 years
old and a mum of 3 she died last night
she'd been on in intensive care and on a
ventilator for a couple of weeks she was
diagnosed with Cova 19 a couple of weeks
ago and being treated at the same
hospital where she worked
certainly I think again these two deaths
will really raise questions about PPE
and whether or not those working on the
front line have the correct personal
protective equipment that they need very
sad news though confirmation of two two
deaths of NHS nurses
okay Katie thank you and just to bring
you a bit more on that we've had a
statement from the hospital where the
second of those two nurses that we
announced the deaths of today was
working
this was the 39 year old nurse Amy
O'Rourke she was a nurse from the Queen
Elizabeth the Queen Mother Hospital in
Margate she died after testing positive
for kovat 19 so says the hospital she
died in the hospital's critical care
unit on Thursday the second of April she
was 39 she joined the acute medical unit
as a newly qualified nurse in 2017 and
ward manager as the ward manager said
that the whole team was devastated by
her death she said she was such a kind
and caring nurse and she had a really
special relationship with her patients
and her colleagues Nursing was something
she'd always wanted to do although she
came to it relatively late after raising
her girls she took some time out to care
for her mom after she was diagnosed with
cancer she was determined to return and
to make her mum proud Amy was a really
valuable part of our work family and
would always offer to help if she could
she was really growing and developing in
her skills and confidence and I know
that she would have gone on to have a
great career that statement coming to us
now from the hospital of Queen Elizabeth
the Queen Mother in Margate where the
nurse Amy O'Rourke has lost her life at
the age of 39